cada una de estas imágenes muestra un
escenario diferente tenemos a una
persona que está a la orilla de un
precipicio en el planeta tierra en el
primer escenario esta persona lanza un
proyectil hacia arriba en el segundo
escenario esta persona lanza un
proyectil de frente es decir ni arriba
ni abajo sino derecho y en el tercer
escenario esta persona lanza el
proyectil con un ángulo hacia abajo lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
usar el vector velocidad inicial de cada
uno de estos escenarios para calcular
cuál es la aceleración con respecto al
tiempo la velocidad con respecto al
tiempo y la posición con respecto al
tiempo tanto en la dirección como en la
dirección x los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta
incluso los invito a que tomen lápiz y
papel para resolverlo antes de que lo
resolvamos en el vídeo vamos a
resolverlos juntos primero analicemos la
aceleración en la dirección vertical
suponemos que nos encontramos en el
planeta tierra y no vamos a tomar en
cuenta la resistencia al aire podemos
imaginar que esta persona se encuentra
en un laboratorio al vacío y tiene
un traje espacial cuál será la
aceleración en la dirección vertical la
aceleración debida a la gravedad será
hacia abajo y será constante suponemos
una aceleración constante por lo que el
vector aceleración vertical se va a ver
así la magnitud de la aceleración debida
a la gravedad es g negativa es negativa
para indicar que su dirección es hacia
abajo
una vez que soltamos el proyectil
comenzará a acelerarse de esta manera
qué pasa con la aceleración en la
dirección horizontal si suponemos que no
hay resistencia al aire entonces no
habrá aceleración o desaceleración en la
dirección horizontal va a permanecer en
cero esto que acabo de dibujar se cumple
para todos los escenarios debido a que
la dirección en la que se lanza el
proyectil no afecta en nada a la
aceleración debida a la gravedad
una vez que soltamos el proyectil ahora
analicemos la velocidad cuál será la
velocidad en la dirección del proyectil
en el primer escenario tomamos el vector
velocidad inicial y lo descomponemos en
sus elementos x
este es el componente en que tomamos la
parte superior de este vector y la
proyectamos aquí a la izquierda así
encontramos la magnitud del componente
en jet aquí abajo tenemos la magnitud
del componente en x el componente
vertical comienza siendo positivo pero
recuerden que la aceleración es negativa
y constante por lo que la velocidad
disminuirá con una razón constante así
que en el primer escenario la velocidad
se ve así y que hay de la velocidad en
la dirección x vemos que comienza siendo
positivo y como no hay resistencia al
aire va a permanecer positivo ya que no
tenemos aceleración en esta dirección la
velocidad permanece positiva como vemos
aquí algo que debemos tener en mente
cuando trabajamos con problemas de
movimiento de proyectiles en dos
dimensiones es que una vez que
descomponemos los vectores en sus
elementos xy ya podemos analizar los de
forma independiente si algo se
desacelera en la dirección y no afecta
en nada lo que pasa en la dirección x
ahora analicemos la velocidad en el
escenario 2 con este vector azul en la
dirección vertical
con cero velocidad así que lo indicamos
aquí una vez que soltamos el proyectil
comenzará a acelerarse hacia abajo la
velocidad aumentará cada vez más en la
dirección negativa conforme pase el
tiempo vean que la pendiente de estas
dos líneas es la misma porque la
aceleración es constante aun cuando
estas líneas tienen un valor inicial
diferente y qué pasa con la velocidad en
la dirección x parece que la velocidad
inicial en x es un poco más grande que
la del primer escenario así que la
dibujamos un poco más arriba pero
también permanece constante todo el
tiempo veamos el último escenario cuál
es la velocidad inicial en que va a
verse así y la velocidad inicial en x se
verá así la velocidad inicial vertical
comienza siendo negativa y conforme pase
el tiempo la velocidad se hará más
negativa cada vez y qué pasa con la
velocidad en la dirección horizontal
parece que ocurre algo muy parecido al
escenario anterior lo dibujamos un poco
más arriba para que lo podamos ver pero
la velocidad en la dirección x permanece
sin cambios
vemos que para todos los escenarios no
tenemos aceleración en la dirección x
finalmente analicemos lo que pasa en la
posición del proyectil en estos tres
casos todos comienzan en la misma
posición tanto en la dirección x como en
la dirección ye pero todos tienen
velocidades iniciales diferentes en la
dirección vertical comencemos con el
primer escenario aquí comenzamos con una
posición positiva en la dirección jeff
pues así lo indica la posición de la
persona que está lanzando el proyectil
en cuanto se libera el proyectil va a
tener una posición positiva pero va a
disminuir conforme pase el tiempo hasta
llegar a este punto en el que la
velocidad del proyectil es cero hasta
antes de este punto la posición del
proyectil en la dirección vertical es
positiva pero va a aumentar más despacio
hasta llegar a este punto en donde la
velocidad se vuelve cada vez más
negativa por lo que la posición en que
luce más o menos así ahora veamos la
posición en la dirección x esta posición
de aquí es el origen de la dirección x y
como tenemos una velocidad constante
positiva
en esta dirección la posición en x se va
a incrementar a una tasa constante en el
segundo escenario comenzamos en la misma
posición para la dirección vertical la
velocidad inicial es cero y después se
hace más negativa la posición luce más o
menos así para la posición x
tenemos una velocidad ligeramente mayor
que la del escenario anterior por lo que
la posición se incrementa con una tasa
constante ligeramente más grande que la
del escenario anterior en el tercer
escenario también comenzamos en la misma
posición pero en este caso comenzamos
con una velocidad negativa que se hará
aún más negativa conforme pase el tiempo
la posición en la dirección y lucirá
algo así para la dirección x tenemos más
o menos la misma velocidad que en el
caso anterior por lo que la posición del
proyectil en esta dirección
va a ser muy parecida a la anterior
esto que acabamos de hacer es una forma
de visualizar cómo se comportan los
proyectiles con respecto a su posición
velocidad y aceleración tanto en la
dirección vertical como en la dirección
horizontal con esto podemos apreciar no
sólo cómo conceptualizar y graficar
estos comportamientos sino también
podemos apreciar el hecho de que al
descomponer los vectores en sus
elementos equis y james podemos analizar
de forma independiente cada dimensión
con esto terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo